turnip commentator ben shapiro
responding to democratic socialists
alexandria Ocasio cortez after being
accused of catcalling for challenging
her to a debate shapiro reacting moments
ago on your world with Neil Cavuto watch
if she were to get into a discussion
with somebody who asks tough questions I
don't think she has the information or
the philosophy at her disposal to
actually answer those questions well and
she knows that which is why her best
move here would have been either to just
ignore or to say no and then everybody
would moved on with their life but
instead it turned into her invoking
victim status why is it Greg that you
can't challenge someone to a debate on
the ideas without being accused of being
a jerk I don't think ben shapiro has
ever catcalled in his life well the
thing is what if a woman had challenged
her to a debate so she's actually being
the sexist I think Candice Owens did oh
really so what did answer your other
question she had to cloak her weak ideas
in the armor of a smear because she's
learned as a leftist the best thing you
can do is smear somebody if you don't
have an argument and the smears actually
work nobody wants to be called sexist or
racist so generally if somebody starts
doing that to you you walk away you say
sorry if it happens on Twitter you just
get off the into it works
unfortunately works we have to learn to
become immune to it but it works and and
I hope they do have the debate actually
debating that makes you our arguments
stronger and I do think that for some of
the people that are interviewing her in
those last couple of weeks and keeps
showing it every day is that she would
benefit Kennedy from having more debate
about her ideas because then she would
strengthen her position if she still
believes in it after she learns the
facts and then could be more persuasive
I have been taking apart some of her
arguments all week long on my Fox
Business show I would love for her to
come on and really sit down and talk
about some of these issues
I wouldn't cat call I don't see ben
shapiro as being a particularly hyper
sexualized person who was a wild man
kennedy to a place where you know
because of his gametes he was somehow
trying to oppress her ladyness that
wasn't happening at all and and he said
you can't answer for some of the claims
that you've made
and one of his questions was named one
sector you would keep private and you
know I don't know that that she would be
a wife cat calling that Richard other
Democrats kind of frustrated that she's
getting so much attention well no it's a
funny story cuz I think if you take the
30,000 foot view on this particular this
case this story it you would say that
she's one person running for one seat
out of 435 different seats Tom Perez
call her the future the deficit he calls
her the future democratic party because
she's young she has energy she's
vivacious she's willing she can answer
basic questions but she represented on a
second Kennedy let me finish
here's that you have with Alexander
O'Connell Cortez she ran against Joe
Crowley a very old and trench Democrat
she beat him by outworking him by out
knocking him by talking to more voters
that's what makes her the future of our
party because she understands it the
only way to win as a Democrat is to
engage in your backyard and have real
conversation her constituents do her
ideals align with the people in New York
third District absolutely but they don't
align with the people in a lot of the
people in Georgia in the Georgia six
district because every race is different
what Republicans are trying to do here
is trying to put the whole Democratic
Party on exactly alexandria Cascio
Cortes so that they could win this
midterm election but we don't have to do
that she's shown herself to be
incompetent because the camera is always
in her face this is a little bit of this
is well well that ben shapiro is talking
about is on the merits there is the pot
I agree with you there is a little bit
of politics going on but on the merits
do you think these issues should be
debated well couple points number one I
haven't heard gametes on television
since third grade with sister Ellen
watching a genetics video so Kennedy
that is huge thank you very much you
made my day there gametes are you cat
calling her but honestly on the left
it's a serious question like you can't
have a conversation without being called
but I call the ista phobic phobophobia
conservative your anything that ends in
an ester of foam now granted yes the
world unfortunately is populated by some
people who think that way
ninety-nine percent of the conservatives
I run into are not those people and this
does nothing for a cause but but
secondly on this I ran for office I lost
it's hard and I want to applaud her on
what she did she went out too and I mean
it she knocked on a lot of doors and she
worked hard but now after winning the
primary and likely going to be the
general election
Victor here it's her responsibility as
Kennedy just said to actually know stuff
and going out there and spouting off
nonsense arithmetic about programs we
can't afford and not having basic
answers that's just completely
irresponsible I just had a thought Greg
do you think that Nancy Pelosi prefers
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes to be out there
taking the heat rather than her because
she became the issue we're doing yeah
well I mean we've we've done Alexandria
every day for the last six months no I I
mean no but it's true but it's always I
mean the thing is she does represent
something she represents kind of like
the naive romanticism that you can you
can kind of play play along and no one
questions of the poems that you write
when you're fifteen years old but I do
think I think you're I think that she
this is a this is a real possibility for
her you know if she does if she does
read and she does actually get up to
speed she could be a challenge but she
hasn't just have some grasp of two
things one she gave the worst
non-defense of Nancy Pelosi and showed
that it's not just the moderate
Democrats who have a problem with the
potential future speaker but it's also
the commies they also don't like her and
then when she was asked how they were
going to pay for Medicare for all she
said will save so much money not having
to pay for those funerals yeah I mean I
think this idea of saying that she does
she doesn't have any facts I mean she
gave a couple of bad interviews she's a
new candidate she's new to the scene we
just like a lot if you admit that she
does she's new to the camera and the
gift the cameras in your face every day
and you're new to the camera and you're
not prepared for that light and maybe
you're not here's the thing but there's
also Republicans who gaff all the time I
mean we could we can we could run Corey
Stewart memes over and over and over
again out of Algeria and he's just as
bad thank God media doesn't do that sort
of thing